it turned out to be a pretty
i think instructive positional game
which just shows you that you gotta
um you gotta be
flexible in your mind
you got to be able to to change your uh
your ideas during the game
you can play for an attack but if you
see that
the benefits of the attack are going to
be
are going to be a positional rather than
material or blurring checkmate then
that's what you need to go for okay i'm
gonna go d6
i'm gonna play a pretty classical
rui lopez in this one
um
yeah i had this against
nakamura i think i got h6 that's what i
did against them
i believe i had this as white against
omnishook as well
back in beale 2008 in that game i
i do think i played bishop c2 though and
he went d5 as i did against nakamura and
what i did in that game was i played d4
and then he played d for knight e4 and
then bishop f5 which i think is kind of
a known trick
which just equalizes the game and
pretty much kills the the excitement
that the spot
um okay so bishop b3 that's normally met
by
bish by knight a5 and then c5
here there is a question
so if i go knight a5 bishop c2 c5 he
goes h3
and then d4 next
where is my counter play because if i
chop off
everything on d4 i'm inevitably going to
be a bit worse
on the other hand probably not a lot
worse so
who cares
if d4 i guess i'm going bishop g4
no bishop g4 d5 what am i thinking
that's insane
it's actually a bit of a bummer
so i gotta take and then i'll go bishop
g4 to get any kind of plane
yeah this is not ideal
and if he does go d5 here in these
structures
h6 is really an unfortunate move to have
made
because it's uh it's a major weakening
of my my king side
so i think here he's possibly
he's possibly quite a bit better
there is a small trick d5 bishop f3
queen f3
i could go knight d5 exploit the pin but
he just goes gf
and i don't think he's remotely worried
about
that double pawn yeah
i mean i i hate bishop 3 but i also hate
the alternatives just gf now
i'm probably just just lost positionally
speaking
yeah i think i have to hope for
for tricks here but tricks can always
happen
so why worry
for four i'm gonna go queen h4 i think
just go for an ending that ending is
by no means great it's just what choice
do i have i can go up with the knight in
g6 i don't want to do that so
i'll go knight b6 i also think queen f6
rp1 was
was pointless probably the queen is not
well placed on f6 that's i'm just
running into
all sorts of uh of attacks
king h2 yeah we'll go g6
again this position would have been
playable if my pawn was in h7 but with
the pawn on
on h6 i don't don't think it is
and if you're wondering why i'm
complaining
while being so far
up in the match and
my position is not like obviously less
is just
strategically inferior then i will just
say that peter sitter
just busted out of the tournament so
somebody has to complain
and
why not uh okay let's go
can you chase next i want to go c4
probably it's just weakening
it's allowing knight d2 then to d4 but
i gotta do something at some point
but on the other hand
it's not that easy for him f5 is
tempting at any point but he has to
reckon with bishop e5
and um you know it's not a it's not
enough to
have a better position i also have to
win the game queen g4 is probably a good
move forcing a
uh considerably better ending possibly
but i don't think that's what he want
what he wants to do i don't think he
wants to exchange queens
but he's got to speed up
queen of three then we go to c4
before nah d4 is not good
b4 i think is a conceptual mistake
because anyway what i wanted was to get
this
square for my pieces but
uh i understand why he wants to go f5
but i don't think this is very good
i mean at the very least i'm getting
loads of control
here knight d5 might lose to knight d6
okay so we've got an a5
which was my first intention anyway
queen g2 yeah i'm gonna take this
i think mariana has lost the thread here
96 there's 93 followed by rook to d8
oh there's fg but i just go fg
that's not a major major worry
hmm
i think there's a rook effect it's very
good
i don't see any any threats that he has
here
fg i think just helps me now i have the
sizes for at the rook f2 as well as
knight of three
but so i think he's just dead lost
oh he has knight of five maybe maybe
knight f5 could have
could have prolonged the game there now
i just went i think
oh wait a sec i have to be a bit careful
rook f1
i wanted knight g oh
okay i've got to speed up g4
i do have a fork though so i should be i
should be winning
okay he lost some time
ah still king h1 knight f2
even maybe knight e3 knight f7 k87
probably wins
okay yeah uh that was yeah that was
actually pretty good
um very decent match
um again don't think he um
he played poorly at all i just think i
made very few blunders and
in general uh played very decently so
i'm i'm
for once pretty happy with uh with my
play
okay thank you guys and see you in scary